look at this footage with the honey and
the Dipper it looks great however this
still doesn't seem right to me we are
doing science here so fortunately we
don't need to guess what seems and what
doesn't seem right this is my favorite
part because this is when we let reality
be our judge and compare to what exactly
happens in the real world so let's do
that whoo there's quite a bit of a
difference because in real ity the honey
is able to support the Dipper oneway
coupling of course cannot simulate this
kind of back and forth
interaction and neither can weak two-way
coupling pull this
off and now let's see yes there we go
the new strong two-way coupling method
finally gets this right